hey everybody this is International
master David proofs for chest comm and
today I'm going to show you the Banco
gambit which is one of blacks
interesting defenses against efore by
white one of their more active and
imbalanced and complicated choices
actually so night of six white has some
options so you can't always play the
Banco you can only play the Banco if
white plays see forum of to pretty much
and then d5 on move three so they can do
other things like play III or play
Knight f3 and you have to you know have
some other opening that you can play in
those cases but the main move in the
most common move is d5 from grandmasters
now in this position white has grabbed a
bunch of space with his two pawns and
black is now going to offer a pawn
sacrifice to try and undermine and
weaken the value of white center with b5
now the main structure that's going to
arise in the Bangko is blacks gonna play
a sex but I want to show you the main
structure that's gonna happen in the
center so ignore this pawn tension with
me for a moment what you're gonna see is
you're gonna see white having a knight
on c3 black having a pawn on d6 pawn on
e4 pawn on g6 and the bishop coming to
g7 now let's talk quickly about the
general features of this kind of a
position what does black have well
generally speaking black has an attempt
at counter play on the Queen side where
they have some number of open files at
least the B file sometimes also the a
file and they've got a very very nice
Bishop on g7 often on this long diagonal
which cooperates with that and a strong
pawn on c5 right because it's defended
that helps give them strength in this
area of the board ok but what does black
need to watch out for well one of the
main things black needs to watch out for
is the move e5 which would break up this
pawn structure here and possibly open a
white attack on the Kings side and
possibly block the bishop on g7 the
other thing black needs to watch out for
sometimes is
the fact that they're down a pond now we
can split up the Banco gambit roughly
between two different approaches though
there are a whole variety of variations
for white but two different approaches
one being to accept the gambit and the
other being not to accept the gambit
if white accepts the gambit then the
bank of gambit will be characterized by
black having better counter play because
he's got two files open and plenty of
space for his pieces right the one extra
worried that black really needs to worry
about in these accepted variations is
the possibility of white playing B three
and a four and creating a healthy pawn
structure with his healthy extra passed
pawn on the a file and eventually
beating black with that extra pawn
instead if you imagine the decline
variations in the decline variations
black is often not going to have as much
space because white won't take creating
extra space for these pieces right so
white might just press their attack in
the center like this or they might play
b6 just making sure you don't get this
square for your pieces the extra thing
the black needs to watch out for in the
decline variations is that they may not
have as much counter play as in the
accepted variations and they may be a
little bit cramped with their pieces on
the coin side so that is the Banco
gambit in a nutshell is a fun opening to
play and you know if you want to spice
things up a little bit more this is an
accepted opening by grandmasters that
you can use to get a more imbalanced
game against one d4 I hope you enjoyed
this video and I'll see you around on
chess calm